so given how huge this trial was given
how eloquent you were you were I know
you don't think of it that way but from
a public perspective you were like the
star
because of how loud
I mean you know uh I'm pretty sure
Camille's the star Camille is also
incredible I've got a chance to interact
with her she's somebody that uh
really inspires me by how good she is at
her job how much she loves her job and
how much the fame the money whatever has
not affected the basic core Integrity of
who she is as a human being so she's
also uh she's also incredible okay uh
how what's the what's the takeaway for
you personally from The Trial uh how is
it made you a better person how is it
changing changed or solidified who you
are as a psychologist as a forensic
psychologist clinical psychologist and
so on
owl uh I mean a lot happened in my life
around that trial leading up to the
trial after the trial
um
so let's tackle forensic psychologists
first sure okay so in terms of forensic
psychology
um I am grateful to that trial for
really strengthening my abilities
um these Stakes were so high that I took
you know I was retained about two years
prior to the trial so
I really delved deep into the academic
side of forensic psychology and making
sure that
um I was adhering as closely as possible
to standard practices best practice
recommendations for this specific type
of an examination it was intellectually
awesome and challenging I feel like my
brain was on fire for a full year
leading up to the trial and that can be
really really fun it was just
challenging but I am really proud of the
work I did I think the stakes were
really high it's serious work it's
important that it's done well and
accurately and
I felt really good about it so I have
some of those lessons carried through to
your practice now to about research and
uh some of the things you're doing in
terms of helping couples
uh no I I mean I just you know my
practice hasn't changed that much uh
this was more uh just something that was
more it demanded so much more of my time
than my typical forensic work does and
personal injury cases are in cases where
there is an allegation of trauma or
psychological harm tend to be super
labor intensive this given um the
magnitude and how long it had been going
on in the back and forth required a ton
of work before the trial as well so it
pulled me away from the practice I think
it's been nice to go back a bit if okay
so now personally
um I've learned some things I've learned
that I need to slow down a little bit uh
so this took a lot from you it took a
lot but it was really the culmination I
feel like there are these hoops we jump
through again and again you know
academic challenges that we continue to
meet and then there's an a next one and
a next one and a next one and in the
beginning like when you're getting into
college or applying to grad schools you
don't really realize this is going to be
a never-ending thing especially if I
continue with research or forensic work
I love it because it is so academic you
know you're writing these 75-page
reports and with citations and
um you have to be accurate it feels like
I'm doing giant board exams again and
again and again
um it never ends but that feeling I
think you and I were talking about how
it's fun to doubt yourself because it
pushes you to do better work
um but so if you keep having high stakes
you're going to work all the time work
yourself in the ground constantly be
thinking I'm about oh this question I'm
not sure if I fully know the answer and
all the research behind that so I should
go there
and again super fun
but
I don't just do forensic psychology all
day I also have own a clinic I provide
therapy I've been providing therapy for
15 years so what happens is you have
clients who maybe you've stopped seeing
but when they have a crisis in their
lives they reach out to you again even
if it's seven years later so you've
accumulated hundreds of clients who at
any given time are going to reach out
when they're in crisis whether or not
you're working on a federal case or in
Virginia for this and
that is never going to be something easy
to Grapple with because I feel that I am
letting somebody down I know I am
because these are people I genuinely
care about and they care about me and
they trust me
and I want to be able to be there for
them I know that it's disappointing if I
can't be and it's also very difficult
to separate out the Professional Therapy
relationship from loving someone who
you've seen through some of the most
difficult parts of their lives and I can
explain that to people all day long but
it doesn't necessarily mean that it's
going to be easy for someone to accept
when I can't talk to them
and they just found out you know their
husband was leading a double life or you
know their sister just died and I can't
even get on a call because I'm getting
maybe 15 messages like that a day
and have to testify and have to run my
practice
um so I think that was why I need to
slow down this case I was doing all of
that
um
and then like the academic load or the
work involved was just tremendous
um and some stuff happened like my dad
he started having his cognitive decline
I got a medical diagnosis that is stress
induced
um I really thought I was getting away
with it I I really believed that people
who talk like a lot about self-care were
kind of full of and just didn't
know how to push themselves I still
believe in pushing ourselves
but I think I
I
kind of traversed into an area and
without realizing it where I was no
longer pushing myself to challenge
myself or see what I was capable of I
was almost pushing myself like as a
necessity because I didn't know what
else to do anymore
just an obligation
um it wasn't even yeah I wasn't pushing
myself to do
the debt herd case reminded me of that
feeling of pushing myself to do
something I wasn't sure I was capable of
and overcoming that challenge that was
rewarding but when you're piling that on
with like running a business and all
these other things and trying to be
perfect at all of them that just starts
to become like a feeling of necessity
and it's not healthy
that said you somehow managed to hold it
all together to put forward a masterful
performance and like you said still take
care of all these clients because you're
the most important person in their lives
for many of them
um is there is there a secret to that
was there any hacks
is there uh sleep a lot I don't get no
and honestly
I it's not 100 it's not I
it's a work in progress right I I don't
have an answer for
I wouldn't want my life to be any other
way I you know I wouldn't have had the
opportunity to work on this case if I
hadn't established my practice and had
Outreach and um
so I I can't figure out like which piece
you take it out without it all crumbling
yeah but I would love to have a little
more down time so it all kind of works
together and there's
passion is the fuel that
uh that's behind all of it probably
that's probably the reason you haven't
lost your mind quite yet maybe yeah
baby unless I mean it depends who you
ask what about the stress of just being
in the public eye has that been
difficult for you
that's a lovely question thank you for
asking it because I'm
it is nice to talk to you about this
because I feel like you probably
understand it a little bit
um that was something I was absolutely
unprepared for uh like I said I had no
idea how many people were watching when
I testified I
I had no idea and I got off the stand I
kind of staggered to the back room and
truly thought about lying down on the
floor because I was so exhausted and uh
you know I'd been up studying on my
stuff terrified that I was gonna forget
some statistic about the mmpi too it's
gonna be so great it's great for me it's
gonna be great for people to hear this
that you're human you're too flaws
that you're that's extremely stressful
for many many hours I wondered how you
could sit there for so many hours and
stay so focused and listen so well it's
so difficult well I mean I could talk
about that too at the moment I came to
almost like came back to my body and
realized where I was and just wanted it
to stop and felt like I was burning
alive I just was thinking I don't want
to do this anymore I don't want to do
this anymore is this going to stop and
then another question came and I just
had to get back to it uh but uh so after
I testified the first time I went in
that back room I I might have laid down
on the ground it's kind of a blur I mean
I might have I do remember that Wayne
Dennison uh one of the senior managing
Partners at Brown redneck who is a
phenomenal guy and absolutely brilliant
I will be indebted in for life because
um I trusted him I trusted him and that
made all the difference in probably how
I testified but he came in the back and
he was looking at his phone and he said
you're on the cover of time something on
you know like Apple news
and I thought I mean I really I thought
he was messing with me
um I thought it was it was his joke way
of saying like I did great